you're not walking away with a check
tonight but you are walking away with a
guy where is this gonna go I'm excited
to see where the future and what it
holds with Matthew we gonna see what
happens I will definitely keep you guys
updated we're gonna hang around
California for a week and then spend
time with each other we haven't known
each other for a single minute outside
of this house so yeah I'm excited to get
to know her a bit outside of the house
and see where it goes
what was it about Matt that he was the
guy for you in the house uh the hip we
bonded over doing dishes and we love a
good prank we love a good bet this is a
funny guy and he accepts me for who I am
I can't have kids and he just was like
most a big deal and so I just I love him
as a person because I mean to give up
$500,000 with somebody says a lot of how
much she cared about me she's just
freaking hilarious man guy I don't even
know what it was exactly because I can't
even understand half the stuff that
comes out of her mouth you shared a lot
of your backstory on the show opened up
a lot
some viewers questioned because there
was so much what do you have to say to
the viewers who may be questioned some
of your backstory I mean if you want a
question and that's my everyone has a
right to their own opinion but I just
really wanted to be an open book I do
have a lot wrong with me and I didn't
use it as a crutch I just wanted to
educate people and inspire people like
okay look I have all this wrong with me
I'm on the show and I'm able to do it I
believe everything Raven said in the
house I mean maybe viewers did question
it but that's if she was making that
stuff up that's a heck that's a heck of
a good story because that is very unique
so yeah maybe maybe some of it wasn't
true and I'm assuming she'll let me know
if it wasn't but I mean I did see the
scar on the pacemaker so I'm assuming
that at least part it had to be true I'd
be like well you don't look sick and
I've had that even before on the show
like the first you don't look sick who
you can't see it there's something wrong
with me in this side and I do have a lot
wrong with me and you clear this up I
house my mom would be a part of Mensa
and she was law school unfortunately she
got sick and did not was not able to
graduate but she could join him into the
morrow she's a very intelligent woman
and I'm very proud to be her daughter
say yeah I mean I'm a sick woman and I
know that I do have terminal illnesses
but I don't let it stop me I don't want
to get me down
[Music]